Luffy is SO GOOD with his devil fruit that it is
basically the only power he needs for the entire
first half of the story. But then THIS HAPPENS,
and then THIS and he suddenly realizes that he
needs top tier haki similar to the likes Shanks or
Roger so that he can survive in the New World. But
THEN after seeing how overpowered he becomes
using haki in the second half of the story,
I just couldn’t stop wondering, how
strong Luffy COULD have been if he
never ate his devil fruit at all and instead
had trained ONLY haki ever since he was a kid?
And this would most likely happen all the
way back when Luffy got his devil fruit.
Because let’s assume that the Red-Hair pirates
don’t completely lose track of the single most
valuable devil fruit, so when hungry child
Luffy is looking around for something to eat,
Shanks keeps the treasure box with the devil
fruit out of his reach. And even though kid
Luffy is desperate to see what is in the box,
Shanks says no. So goodbye stretchy Luffy.
But that’s not all that is different about his
back story, because even without his rubber
abilities he’s still the impulsive kid we know
and love, so when he insults these bandits he is
still going to get captured, taken out to sea,
and has to be rescued by Shanks because even
though he can now swim, he’s still no match for
this monstrous sea king. But now we get the NEXT
MAJOR twist because when they get back to land,
Luffy suddenly has A TON of questions about how
Shanks scared away the sea king. Now since this
version of Luffy doesn’t have his devil fruit,
Shanks decides to show Luffy the very basics of
haki so he can grow strong and protect himself.
And I’m talking specifically about armament and
observation haki here since Luffy hasn’t awakened
his conqueror’s haki yet. Although I guess it
is possible that Shanks could assume that Luffy
has conquerors because of his dad and grandpa, so
he might even tell Luffy about all three powers.
However, this is where we run into
our first major debate. Because when
Shanks is about to depart in the original
story, he gives Luffy the straw hat as a
symbol of his belief in the young boy.
At least that’s what we always thought,
but there is also the very real possibility that
Shanks only tried to inspire Luffy BECAUSE HE ATE
this particular devil fruit. That’s because
this devil fruit is extra special and we can
only assume it is required in order to become Joy
Boy, which Luffy just managed to achieve in Wano.
So the big question is, would Shanks still give
up his hat if Luffy doesn’t have the devil fruit?
I’m honestly not sure, but I think that Luffy’s
personality would still inspire Shanks. Plus it
is still possible for Luffy to find Laugh Tale and
become pirate king without becoming Joy Boy - I
mean Roger did it - so let’s assume Luffy still
gets the hat and Shanks even tells him that he
might even tell him more about what was in that
treasure chest when Luffy becomes a great pirate.
Which leaves us with the ABSOLUTE CRAZY SCENARIO
of Luffy growing up training his haki instead of
his devil fruit powers. I mean can you imagine
him running around the Goa Kingdom blasting off
haki punches?! He would be insanely strong! And
I honestly think his grandpa Garp would be SO
HAPPY to see his Grandson learning haki
that he might even train Luffy himself,
which ultimately means that Luffy’s fighting style
will be VERY SIMILAR to Garp’s where he mainly
fights with his fists. Although I suppose there
is a decent chance Luffy might eventually learn
to use a weapon since most haki-only powerhouses
like Roger and Shanks use a weapon as well.
In fact, I HAVE THE PERFECT WEAPON for Haki Luffy
to use which we’ll discuss a little later on,
but first Luffy would probably also awaken his
conqueror’s haki during his time growing up,
perhaps when he was captured by bandits
or maybe when Sabo “died”. Which means
that by the time Luffy is ready to start his
pirate adventure his haki skill has leveled
up from noob to master and he’s basically
at the same level he was right after the
timeskip. But we’ll see VERY SOON how long
he can survive without his devil fruit.
What you may not even realize though is that
not having a devil fruit is actually going to
save his life more than once in the East Blue.
Because while most of the enemies in this part
of the story were fairly easy to beat, you
may have forgotten that Rubber Luffy almost
drowned TWICE! Once when he was thrown off the
Baratie and once when he dropped into the water
like an anchor while fighting Arlong. Both
times he had to be saved by others, but that
is no longer a problem because this version
of Luffy has no restrictions with swimming,
so defeating his enemies becomes a simple problem
of smashing their faces with his haki-covered
kicks and punches. Plus his observation haki will
help him dodge attacks like Arlong’s spinning
torpedo and he would even be able to easily
break weapons with his haki-infused attacks.
But the most insane part of Luffy’s new abilities
is that he would definitely be able to overcome
his VERY FIRST DEFEAT against the Logia fruit
using Captain Smoker. Because if you remember
Luffy only really struggled against opponents who
had Logia devil fruits because he simply could not
hit them without knowing their elemental weakness
or having haki. But that’s literally not a problem
at all this time. Because once Luffy figures
out his haki-punches can hit Smoker, I don’t
think there is any way the marine captain will
defeat Luffy. Which might mean that his bounty
is WAY HIGHER heading into the Grand Line, which
might actually be a serious problem later on.
At this point, I also think we should mention
that if Luffy knows haki he might also teach
other members of the crew what he knows about
haki. Although, let’s be honest he’s probably not
the greatest teacher, and he might just tell them
to figure it out on their own. But being around
Luffy and seeing him use his haki abilities could
mean that characters like Zoro and Sanji figure
out how to use haki much earlier in the story.
So a major overall power boost for the crew.
Which takes us straight through the Alabasta
Saga to the eventual clash with the Warlord,
Crocodile. Now in the original story, Luffy
had to fight Crocodile THREE TIMES and there
is no doubt that he would have died each time
if it weren’t for help from other people and a
ton of luck. But once again, haki is going
to COMPLETELY CHANGE these fights. Because
the ability to hit Logia fruit users is just so
overpowered that Luffy should be able to deal
heavy damage to Crocodile right away. However,
this isn’t to say this fight would be easy,
especially since Luffy can only basically attack
from close range since he can’t stretch his body.
But Crocodile might also be super surprised
to find someone in this part of the world who
can use haki, so really there’s no doubt in
my mind that Haki Luffy would find a way to
win and save his friend Vivi’s kingdom.
Whew, so far so good for Haki Luffy, but
let’s see if he can actually survive against the
strongest characters like the one coming up next.
And that’s because things are about to get
IMPOSSIBLY DIFFICULT when the crew flies
up to Skypiea. It’s here that they come
face to face with the Lightning God Enel
and Luffy is going to need a MASSIVE power
boost to take him down. Let’s explain why.
In case you forgot, the ONLY WAY that Luffy was
originally able to defeat Enel was because of his
rubber body’s natural immunity to electricity. So
Enel’s main attacks were basically worthless. But
that advantage is out the window now, so at this
point, Luffy is in serious danger of getting one
shot by this electric powerhouse. And yes, just
like with Crocodile, Luffy can easily damage the
logia fruit user with his haki, but the problem
is getting close to Enel. It doesn’t matter how
hard you punch if you get your heart fried
before you even get close enough to attack.
However, Skypiea also is the PERFECT
OPPORTUNITY to introduce two new
power ups for Haki Luffy. The first is
that we know Luffy is a haki prodigy,
which means he is super good at learning
the basic and advanced techniques,
so I think that after pushing his observation haki
to the ABSOLUTE MAX when dodging Enel’s lighting
bolts it is quite realistic for him to awaken
advanced observation haki during this fight.
And doing so would let him see a few seconds
into the future and give him a huge advantage.
But if that isn’t enough, Luffy also gains another
HUGE BONUS by not being a devil fruit user. That’s
because in the original story we already saw
this Shandian warrior use Sea Prism Stone to
help him nearly kill Enel. And normally Sea Prism
Stone drains the power of any devil fruit user,
but now that Luffy is devil fruit free, he
could also somehow use these stones to gain
an advantage against Enel. I can just imagine
Usopp somehow making him some Sea Stone brass
knuckles so his punches would do extra damage
to devil fruit users. Which, let's be real,
is almost every single one of Luffy’s
fights. So with all this put together,
Haki Luffy should be able to
take down Enel and save Skypiea.
But that’s not going to be enough to
save Haki Luffy from being COMPLETELY
OVERWHELMED by admiral Aokiji. In the
original story, he was completely washed
by the admiral’s ice logia powers. And even
though Haki Luffy will probably land a few
blows, I still don’t think he comes close
to winning this fight. But we’ll see if
that is still the case the next time that
Luffy fights an admiral in just a minute.
However, while they eventually survived
that encounter with the admiral, Luffy’s
missing devil fruit will play a MAJOR ROLE in the
outcome of the next battle. Because after Robin
was kidnapped by the government secret agents
Luffy needed not one but TWO MASSIVE POWER UPS
to defeat the leopard-man Rob Lucci. Those would
be Gear 2, which gave him an incredible boost in
strength and speed, plus Gear Three which allowed
Luffy to increase the size of his fists. But again
these upgrades are gone! So what is Luffy going
to do now? Well, there are a few options that
could work. First, Haki Luffy could just be so
stupidly powerful that he beats Lucci without any
upgrades. And honestly I think this is perfectly
valid, but if that doesn’t satisfy you then we can
also consider that the entire crew is probably
stronger from seeing Luffy’s haki in action.
So perhaps Zoro and Sanji defeat their opponents
much faster and then they can help their captain.
Either way the crew should free Robin,
escape after a clash with Luffy’s Grandpa,
and then breeze through Thriller Bark to
reach Sabaody. But this is where things
are going to go ABSOLUTELY CRAZY, and it
all starts by you hitting that nice red
subscribe button for more one
piece content just like this.
But here in Sabaody is where Haki Luffy will
truly be tested for the first time. And we
could assume that Luffy’s advanced observation
haki will help him make sure this mermaid never
gets kidnapped in the first place. However, that
takes a lot of the fun out of this arc, so let’s
imagine that Luffy still punches a World Noble
which means that Admiral Kizaru and the cyborg
Pacificstas come to hunt them down. So here is
where Haki Luffy is really going to shine. Because
if we are assuming he started his journey with
haki skill as good as right after the time skip,
then he should be able to crush the Pacificsta no
problem, right? I mean just look at what he did to
this one before they left for Fishman Island. Plus
he’s grown stronger through all of his fights,
so I honestly don’t see the Pacifistas being
that much of a problem for the Straw Hats.
Which means we have to ask if they would still
need to be separated by the Warlord Bartholemew
Kuma? I mean, I think Luffy at this point
might put up a better fight against Kizaru,
but he still wouldn’t be able to take him down
alone. So if Rayleigh is there to hold off the
admiral there is a great chance the crew
could escape together. On the other hand,
if Kuma really was determined to send them
all over the world there is nothing Luffy
could do about it at this point. Haki isn’t
going to stop the awesome pushing power. Plus
they wouldn’t be able to go to Fishman
Island yet without coating the ship,
so let’s imagine that the story follows its normal
path and they all get separated like normal.
Now before we see that HUGE IMPACT THAT Luffy is
going to make at Marineford, but first I think
his path to getting to this epic war would go
pretty similarly to the original. Although on the
Island of Women, the pirate Empress Boa Hancock
might fall in love right from the start because
of Luffy’s overwhelming conqueror’s haki and
kindness. But Impel Down wouldn’t change all
that much. He still wouldn’t be able to punch
the venomous warden, so no big changes here.
However, when Luffy drops into Marineford, I could
definitely see him charging into the war with his
full conqueror’s haki blazing. And can you just
imagine the insanity of an entire battlefield of
marines and pirates turning to see this madman
dropping in from the sky?! A bunch of the weaker
enemies would probably drop unconscious on
the spot, and it might even force an admiral
to come after Luffy right away because he is
an unknown threat at this point. And speaking
of the admirals, they are honestly some of the
few characters who can stop Haki Luffy at this
point. Them plus Garp, the Fleet Admiral Sengoku,
or the world’s strongest swordsman Mihawk are
truly their only hope. Honestly, I don’t even
think Doflamingo could stop Haki-Luffy with his
current power level. So Luffy would definitely
square off with someone like Kizaru. But instead
of being easily sniped like in the original war,
Luffy should puts up a decent fight because of
his advanced observation and the fact that he
can actually hit the light logia fruit user.
Which might mean that the Whitebeard pirates
stand a WAY BETTER chance of succeeding in
rescuing Ace. Because if Luffy is taking the
attention of an admiral all by himself that
means the strongest allied pirates like the
Emperor Whitebeard, Marco the Phoenix, and the
escaped prisoners like Crocodile and the fishman
Jinbe would get much closer to rescuing Ace.
But sadly, just because Luffy is way stronger
that doesn’t mean he is strong enough to win a
one on one with an admiral, so let’s imagine
he gets away and frees Ace just like in the
original story. Hold on, wait, that just means
we are heading straight to Donut Ace again,
right? Well, let’s find out. Because with Luffy’s
Advanced Observation he should be able to sense
Admiral Akainu coming and at least dodge his
fiery magma fist. But he honestly wouldn’t be
able to run away forever, and even if he is able
to block a magma punch then it would most likely
send him flying across the battlefield. And with
Whitebeard suffering his normal heart attack,
that unfortunately leaves Ace to
once again get killed by Akainu.
*Fake cry.* Almost Ace. You
almost made it this time.
So with the major turning point over,
let’s assume Shanks arrives to stop
the war and Luffy escapes like normal.
Which gives us one MAJOR QUESTION to ask.
Would there need to be a timeskip in this
scenario? Because if you remember Rayleigh
came to train Luffy with the main goal of
teaching him hakiBut since Luffy already
is well on his way to being a haki master,
is that even necessary? Well, honestly I think
yes. Because in our version of the story,
the rest of the crew is still separated and they
could definitely use time to train. Plus I think
it would be a huge waste for Luffy to not train
with one of the few legitimate haki masters,
so let’s assume that Rayleigh does train Luffy for
the normal timeskip, but instead of learning basic
haki, Rayleigh puts him through a BRUTAL training
regiment that helps him master Advanced Armament
and possibly also advanced conqueror’s.
Although I must admit that Luffy probably
wouldn’t master this last one yet because as we
know, haki blooms most during intense battle.
However, all this means that after the timeskip,
Haki Luffy and the straw hats are way overpowered
for the rest of the New World. Honestly I could
see this version of Luffy one-shotting the
post-time skip opponents like this roided out
fishman, this gas man, and the pink flamingo.
Which just leaves Luffy to fight against the
Emperor’s Big Mom and Kaido. And during the
Whole Cake Island Arc we would get one of the most
interesting clashes against Big Mom’s strongest
son, Katakuri. Because for much of this original
fight Katakuri didn’t respect Luffy as a fighter.
And for good reason. Katakuri was clearly stronger
with his superior armament haki AND future sight
haki. But in this version of the story, there
is no doubt that Luffy has the upper hand. So
I wonder if Katakuri would really even go so far
as to fight Luffy. Or would they even clash at
all? I mean Luffy might just be able to kick him
off the ship which would allow the crew to Coup
De Burst away on the Sunny. Luffy might also have
a longer clash with Big Mom during this arc, but
since his real goal was to just rescue Sanji and
leave, I don’t think they’d go all out just yet.
So onto Wano-kuni and the BIGGEST CONTROVERSY YET.
Because this is the scene of Luffy's biggest test
against the Strongest Creature in the Sea, Kadio.
And honestly, I’m going to drop a hot take here
because if Luffy is facing Kaido while already
having a ton of experience with Advanced Armament
haki, future sight, and he understands the basics
of Advanced Conquerors, then I truly don’t see how
Kaido can beat him. Because Luffy was beat down
so much during his original fight with Kaido,
and it wasn’t until he learned advanced
conquerors that he was actually able to
do any real damage to the King of the Beasts.
And although Luffy even had to awaken Gear 5 to
eventually beat the oni-dragon, by that point he
was already exhausted. So if Luffy has basically
his strongest abilities from the very start of
the battle, then I think his insane will power,
durability, and overall haki mastery will
lead him to defeat Kaido once and for all.
BUT… AND THIS IS A BIG BUT! That leaves us
with a SUPER IMPORTANT question. Without
unlocking Gear 5 can Luffy still become
Joy Boy and bring freedom to the world?
Well, honestly I think no. I mean it was pretty
clear in the original story that it was only
after Luffy awakened Gear 5 that this giant
elephant officially recognized him as Joy Boy.
So without his legendary Nika devil fruit, it
just isn’t possible. But, remember that little
promise Shanks made to Luffy at the start of this
video. Let’s discuss that more in just a moment.
Because from here, I think Luffy has a pretty
clear path to finding Laugh Tale and becoming
pirate king. And we know he doesn’t need
to be Joy Boy to find Laught Tale since
Roger was able to do it. So the question
would be could Luffy still use whatever
treasure was left at Laugh Tale and go on to
save the world without being Joy Boy? Well,
we don’t really know, but this could also be
the perfect time for Luffy and Shanks to meet,
and if Shanks has been holding onto the Nika
fruit all this time then he could very well
offer it to Luffy if he truly believes
Luffy is destined to become Joy Boy.
Now, I don’t know if Haki Luffy would all of a
sudden want to eat a devil fruit, and even if
he did it might take him some time to awaken it,
but if this is a required step to save the world,
I could see Luffy doing it. Which might be a
bit disappointing since he came all this way
with just his haki, but since he’s already
eating one, why don’t we make things EVEN
CRAZIER by giving him a SECOND DEVIL fruit
as well?! WHICH SOUNDS COMPLETELY WILD,
but can you imagine if Luffy had two devil
fruits at the start of the story? So if you
want to know which powers would combine
with his original fruit best and how it
would COMPLETELY CHANGE his adventure,
you can watch that video right here.
Shanks for watching and I’ll
see you in the next one.
###